EDITOR NICK UM TOLL OF THEIAIN
WANT TO WARN OUR VIEWEHEPHIC.
NAMED AND NUMBERS.
RUSSIA'S UNPROVOKED INVASION
KILLANUMDI OUT WHO AND H.R
ADDRESS THE SMELL.
ITIM P O
POSITION.Y
THESE ARE TANKNSE CITY.
PRES FOR THE RUSSIANS CCUPIED I.
BURYING THESE BODIES WHERE
THE CITY.AYO REST
CIALHAVEER
400 BO W HERE.EVENHIIN VIOLENT
THROUGH THE  BEEN
DOZENS OFST INDIVIDUAL GRAV, N.
ONE BURYING A NUMBERS HIGH AS
398.
, WED, A
SMELL AND SEE,
WE'RE 17D , A POLICEMAN HERE TO
FOUND INCLUDING THE FAMILY IN AN
JUSTY A NUMBER.D OTHERS HAVE ME
RITHIS INVESTIR US
SPOT.
toITARY ONESURTHER
EREXE
AND  BNT FORERVESTIGorr: TO BEHE
HUOF
PEOPLE NOW WHO THER
BUG ANOTHERS
MPSITE.
TH FIRST HIT WITH AN
AIR N MOVED IN.RIED NOT T OUT B.
WH THEIR SAL
MACHINESTHEY D TRENCHES FOR
WE ONLY HEARD HOW THEY WERE NG
IFREIGG JUF HEAVY TRUCKS
FIS OF THIF NIGHTSE SAW VIWN ASK
PA ONILBE WRITTEN AND NOTHING C
TO WHAT YOE TO BUTCH LIKENHASE
YU WHERE CIVILIANS
DEAD IN CLEAR WHAT I
CRIMES.
THIS SCENE HAS IT SE
UKRAINE OFFICIALS
HAMA
IPS DEPARTMENTS BUT I SHOULD
POINT OUT MANY OF THE   TBE AND
PEOPLE WHO WERE N OUT OF THE TH
DIE.RSE S ULTIMALY
PEOPLE WHO EXPIE VIOLENT
BUT MAYBE SOME OF E LE
DIED IN THE ONSLAUGHT ORURONA L